antenne 2 et philips vous présente le
bar de la plage l'émission d'été de
thierry ardisson
où
le vieux piano delà plat du jour console
quand solitude
vieux pianos de la plage à des clients
dont l'habitude de danser
il dimanche les autres jours s'allongent
sur les planches
il se souvient il rêve et son
c'est alors le sont tout court vêtues de
ma cachette et que soudain de rang
en blanc et muet en lui chemin inverse
mais c'est une houle ou tout ce que je
vois tour comme cette musique jali mais
poro
me fait du mal me fait du bien non c'est
pas rien
bonsoir bienvenue au bar de la plage
avec catherine lara les vacances de son
enfance plus confidences michel delpech
à la pêche aux souvenirs celui qui s'est
fait piquer par le garde-chasse du
gourma la plage à la page bercoff ivres
de livres baffie en gendarme de saint
tropez permis à points dans la gueule ou
comment les mecs essai de coucher en
caméra cachée et le barman nersessian
celui qui bloqua bonne escient
voici le bar de la plage et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de nos latitudes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible ou